هل ثلاثه ايام من اضراب الاطباء غير
الاستشاريين في بريطانيا كفيله برفع عدد
الوفيات نعم بحسب مزاعم صحيفه التليجراف
المحسوبه على حزب المحافظين والتي نشرت
ارقاما صادمه حيث تقول الصحيفه ان هناك
اكثر من 21 وفاء اضافيه خلال اسبوع في شهر
مارس الماضي الرقم هذا طبعا زياده عن
المعدل المعتاد بنسبه 11% من الوفيات
المعتاده اضراب الاطباء غير الاستشاريين
او من يعرفون بالجونيه دام ثلاثه ايام فقط
ما ادى الى زياده ساعات الانتظار في قسم
الطوارئ لاكثر من اثنتي عشره ساعه في بعض
الاحيان وتشير التلغراف الى تاجيل
175 الف عمليه وارتفاع عدد المرضى على
لائحه الانتظار الى اكثر من سبعه ملايين
شخص نشر هذه الارقام من قبل التلغراف
يتزامن مع اضراب سبعه واربعين الف طبيب
اربعه ايام هذا الاسبوع وسط صراع شرس بين
حكومه المحافظين واطباء هيئه الخدمه
الصحيه الوطنيه ويشار الى ان معدل اجري
طبيب غير استشاري 3000 جنيه بالشهر فقط من
لندن عروب عبد الحق العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات